what's going on reject nation it's Greg
Alva here it's John over here and it's
Andrew over here today's that big day at
comic-con thor ragnarok trailer has just
been released you know what let's do
let's just do it
so much has happened to go to our soil
we lost Miami like yesterday depression
happened on the journey of
self-discovery
[Music]
love the logo why are we you have no
idea
[Music]
Oh a hot ball is like this me how told I
was easy
[Music]
it'll be reborn in line what you because
see
you discover hidden everything like
earlier the end of everything
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
front row
I'm a month
[Music]
what were you to god all again
oh yeah there's a mune I'm just a couple
hot-headed fools here say awk like tired
or like water kind of like fire the
whole makings like wow okay oh okay
what's the process that looks incredible
Wow
I feel like Kate Blanchette tell is
going to be a fantastic character I
really think that she's going to be a
wonderful villain because not only a
Cate Blanchett just a great actress but
the way they're showing her powers off
in this trailer looks incredible the
chemistry between Mark Ruffalo and Chris
Hemsworth looks fantastic because that's
what seeing those scenes I was thinking
to myself I don't remember these two
characters really interacting and prior
marbled instalments the other thing I
remember is that Ultron a little bit a
little bit of in age of Ultron and I
remember that a special like vlog video
they did you know where Thor was like in
between Captain America Civil War I
remember their temperature Dara seemed
really good they seem like they're
playing off each other fantastically in
this trailer talking Hulk I can get on
board with that I guess I'm like you
have oregano maybe to wonder if that's
who they're using I think so
marble is really transferring over to
the cosmic territory it looks fantastic
it looks a lot it looks like a lot of
fun I feel like this could be the best
Thor solo movie we get and and also
Chris Hemsworth's just looks like he's
having way more fun this time around he
looks like he's having a blast on set
the main thing for me with this movie is
fun like this is probably the one I'm
most looking forward to out of all the
upcoming Marvel stuff on sheer terms of
enjoy ability like the look of it I love
that they're going full-bore with not
only the sort of sci-fi stuff but also
you know like the fantasy I'm getting
like Lord of the Rings vibes you know
with more lasers and more you know
craziness so one thing I took away most
from this trailer is just how striking
all of those tableaus are those images
that look like fantasy painting yeah you
know with horns and wings and armies
cresting at each other this
looks dows it looks like a good 3d movie
and Oh going off your thing about Loki
I feel like this movie will have a
stronger sense of self-awareness than
the other ones especially considering
the director that's doing it I feel like
there will be a bigger sense of
self-awareness which I think could work
for this film and it's a totally
different direction than what the other
Thor movies were and I feel like in the
Thor standalone movies need a little bit
of a fresh feel to them even when Loki
shows up he's like surprised like i
winking at the audience like yeah you
knew this was coming
yeah yeah and you know maybe that will
be and maybe this will kind of put a
fresh stamp on the Loki character Casino
there was some stuff this happened with
that character over time really Oh weird
yeah I'm excited to see where they take
him next and also just just putting
Bruce Banner putting Hulk in here as a
bigger character I think it's a really
nice idea too
because that seems to be the most
problematic of all the main Marvel
characters right now so maybe if we get
to know him a little bit more through
the scope of this movie pairing him on
Thor I think that's a cool idea too that
could maybe lead to another solo Hulk
adventure down the road I don't
personally see that happening because
Universal owns the distributing rights
but we'll see hopefully that has
happened but we'll say just going off
this trailer what I loved about this
trailer like you said it's a lot of fun
but it doesn't give a lot of weight it
doesn't spoil the only thing so I mean
it's got some parts from the other
trailer but it adds a few different
things like visually we see some really
cool shots hella looks menacing she
looks great the thing that gets me
besides all her crazy like little talks
which he said when she's taunting her
enemy or whatever look how nice of
enemies are around surrounding her
there's an army of Asgardians versus one
person or one you know character from
nifelheim that the ruler of Nippon but
that just shows you how powerful you
need an army to fight her just one
character and it's cool to see you know
him and Thor interacting about who won
the battle I thought that was funny but
the big money shot of this entire
trailer for me was seeing
Lawrence or the Firelord Surgery at the
end and if you know anything about the
Firelord sir he's the he basically rules
over muscle hime which is one of the
nine realms and I wanted to see this
character forever so but also we kind of
got a little glimpse of
I'm in for the dark world of film I'm
not a very big fan of but we see one of
the nine realms and they're all merging
at the end you see muscle Hymas in there
and it's one of the nine realms I've
been waiting to see Muslim and obviously
everyone's looking forward to the Thor
versus Hulk battle I'm looking forward
to seeing them fighting sort of
obviously whenever they battle hella
that was some crow when she catches
Monier reminds me of Winter Soldier
catching the Captain America shield and
Winter Soldier so after all like damn
she's powerful to catch Monier that
easily but seeing the Fire Lord sir like
I've been waiting forever the visual
shot at the end it was so beautiful and
seeing I think it was hot with it Hulk
going after that sir I couldn't tell us
was Hulk earth or either way I am locked
in I can't wait to see us I mean
obviously we got Infinity Ward black
panther after I'm just locked in and
focused on this and we'll get to those
after that but I loved what I saw this
this looks like it had the potential to
expand the Marvel Universe the same way
the guardians of the galaxy did but just
in a different because still kind of
eighties tinge but any different more
fantasy oriented ring oh yeah also I
like that they're forming like another
new kind of team with it you know cuz
guardians as a team the Avengers as a
team all together they're a team but now
we're getting another day we knew his
star Thor had a team before now it's at
different times and it was for Hulk
Valkyrie and Loki we saw that too yeah
are we going to see the soul gem come
out because obviously we need to that's
the only stone we have not seen yet in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe are we
finally going to see that in this film
and is it going to be is it hello that
has it is it Heindel that has it like
it's going to be interesting to see
where that comes from because obviously
we know fan nose is coming in Infinity
Ward he's going to need all those stones
and we've been introduced to every
single one of them now except for the
sold sonís it could be double blue he
has it or it could be Sam Neill he's in
the movie too one other thing that I
have a little theory of in the comics
Loki is hellas father I think because we
saw in the first door laughs II was you
know the the frost giant King he was the
one that was introduced as Loki's father
he abandoned him and now the old father
is his adoptive father we know Frigga
Renee Russo's character was his adoptive
mother I think they're going to reveal
possibly in the film that hella is his
mother I think that would be really
annoying yeah there'd be exactly where
similar hat yeah and also to seeing her
in that antler head like in the comics
when she wears
basically a cloak it really is
strengthens her a lot so when look like
when she was going in a bow she's
wearing that antler had a lot of big
time and I love what it represents
visually represent I am freaking about
to destroy and slaughter an army right
now and it just means bills to her
intensity and her like wow I feel such
great tension and in the danger for
these characters and even though we know
Thor is going to make it in a very well
I don't it does americans I feel like
the stakes are so high it's going to add
so much more weight to the story when
we're inside when we're watching it in
theater I just can't wait to this looks
incredible and I also love the 80s theme
spot that they're going out there are so
cool I love it call Robin after being a
judge dredd now he's in a different
Marvel world now so she was a shaved
head yeah she had it was a lot more gun
action in this trailer - yeah yeah even
Thor Loki or holding gun well go ahead
when the executioner had guns in the
first room like what is he wearing a
Judge Dredd helmet alright guys well
thanks for it I lady Asano is out you
can subscribe to the real rejects click
that notification ballot - on Humphrey
on Twitter and Instagram
this guy is a Gore 7-eleven on Twitter
and Instagram but more importantly
follow him at the movie source channel
on YouTube go ahead and do it check out
our patreon for exclusive goodies much
love